all right don mccarthy beauty and
lifestyle advisor of dawn's corner has
some great products to help you get
ready for back to school or back to work
check it out
hi las vegas first up
wow skin science apples aren't only
great for teachers but also to clarify
and detox your hair and skin
packed with ultra rich natural
ingredients this amazon top selling wow
apple cider vinegar shampoo and coconut
avocado conditioner is the dynamic duo
solution to revive your hair before
heading back into the classroom
it's suitable for all hair types it'll
leave your hair smoother stronger and
flake free and for under thirty dollars
yes please
another top pick from wow skin science
if you are looking for brighter balanced
skin check out their wow apple cider
vinegar foaming face wash which has a
built-in silicone brush that gently
exfoliates to deep clean pores removes
impurities and helps banish breakouts
all for under fifteen dollars go to buy
wow dot com
now do you wanna feel summer smooth and
sun kissed all year long i have just the
solution
completely bare don't grow glow not only
helps reduce hair density length and
growth but also gradually builds your
tan and provides long lasting hydration
and it does smell great too it's
formulated with plant-based ingredients
including shea butter white willow bark
and without parabens and phthalates
don't grow glow is pita certified
cruelty free and vegan this is a must
have product if you are wanting
filter-free looking legs for back to
school it's available at
completelybear.com
next one of my favorite bars the g2g
protein bar it comes in eight delicious
flavors has 18 grams of protein no
preservatives making them the perfect
on-the-go bar
g2g bars are derived from whey isolate
freshly ground nut butters and certified
gluten-free organic oats they are the
perfect go-to bars before heading back
to class
work or the gym
whey protein is a complete protein that
contains all essential amino acids which
is going to aid in muscle growth and
prevents muscle loss
whey protein is also very digestible and
has been shown to reduce inflammation
and these bars are just simply creamy
rich and taste delicious
and right now g2g is offering two free
bars on their website so people can try
the bars with no expense yes free
shipping as well for these free bars so
go to g2gbar.com
and one of my top picks would be the
peanut butter chocolate chip
lastly introducing elfster
this free gift exchange global website
and app increases wish fulfillment by
making holidays birthdays back to school
and everyday gift giving easier with its
secret santa generator
participants are going to form a group
add items to their wish list and the
site assigns givers
the site has its pulse on trends offers
curated gift guides including hot items
just for back to school like these
products here
so if you're a teacher parent or student
get started today by going to
elfster.com to make all your wishes come
true
now if you want more information on any
of these products i featured just go to
dawnscorner.com
all right thank you don there's more las
vegas now coming up and